Some of them might save Middle-Earth… and
some of them might destroy it.
From fateful decisions to political intrigue
to the greedy pursuit of treasure, the characters
of "The Rings of Power" have lived dramatic
lives.
Here's what you need to know about all of
them.
Galadriel is no stranger to fans of "The Lord
of the Rings."
The Lady of Lórien is one of the most memorable
and important characters Tolkien ever created,
and Cate Blanchett's portrayal of her in the
movie adaptations is nothing less than iconic.
The version of Galadriel we meet in "The Rings
of Power," however, may not be the one you're expecting.
This story begins in a time of relative peace,
after the defeat of the Dark Lord Morgoth
and the world-shattering War of Wrath that
closed out the First Age.
Galadriel is considerably more brazen at this
point, as she hunts down the remnants of Morgoth's
forces to avenge her brother's death.
After she completes her mission and abandons
her journey back into the west, Galadriel
encounters Halbrand, a mortal man whose fate
is apparently intertwined with that of the
future Elf-queen.
Before that fateful encounter, though, she
spends time with Elrond in the Elven realm
of Lindon.
And eventually even sets foot on the island
realm of Númenor.
Considering the breadth of these travels,
it's clear that this more reckless Galadriel
is one of the main characters of "The Rings
of Power," if not the outright protagonist.
During the Third Age, Elrond is one of the
most highly respected and experienced Elf-lords
still in Middle-earth.
You're probably well aware of his role in
Tolkien's more famous works.
In "The Hobbit," he briefly allows Thorin
Oakenshield's company to stay in Rivendell.
In "The Lord of the Rings," he heals Frodo
after the attack on Weathertop, hosts the
Council of Elrond, and then takes one of the
last ships into the west.
"The Rings of Power" features a very different
Elrond.
At this point, still young and determined,
Elrond plays a part in the politics-heavy
Lindon storyline.
"It is said the wine of victory is sweetest
for those in whose bitter trials it has fermented."
He also pays a visit to the Dwarves of Khazad-dûm,
suggesting the young Elf-lord's politicking
may extend beyond his homeland's borders.
You can expect far greater things from Elrond
as the series goes on.
Throughout the Second Age, he proves himself
as a military commander during the Elves'
conflict with Sauron, establishes Rivendell,
takes possession of Vilya, the Ring of Air,
and helps overthrow the Dark Lord in the War
of the Last Alliance.
There can be little doubt that these events
will be depicted in "The Rings of Power,"
and that, by the end of the series, this young
Elf will have grown into the great leader
he is destined to become.
One of the most exciting aspects of "The Rings
of Power" is that it will bring characters
who have previously been little more than
legends to the screen.
Gil-galad is the High King of the Noldor and
ruler of Lindon, the Elven realm that lies
in the western regions of Middle-earth.
A wise leader and fierce warrior, Gil-galad
appears in a poem recited by Samwise Gamgee,
which tells of his keen lance, shining helm,
silver shield, who eventually falls into darkness.
Indeed, you could reasonably argue that Gil-galad,
as a keen military commander and sworn enemy
of Sauron, is the most important Elf to live
in Middle-earth during the Second Age.
In "The Rings of Power," Gil-galad appears
to be exactly as magnificent as his reputation suggests.
When Galadriel returns from her last mission
to the north, he presides over a ceremony
granting her and her soldiers passage into
the West.
He wears golden robes during the ceremony
and places a crown of golden laurels on Galadriel's head.
Later in the season the Elf-king hosts a magnificent
feast for a few Dwarven visitors including
Durin IV.
These are mere hints towards Gil-galad's greater
importance, of course, but it seems certain
we'll see much, much more of him in the coming
years.
A skilled smith who witnesses the many calamities
of the First Age, Celebrimbor is best known
for forging the Rings of Power.
He first makes several lesser rings, crafted
under the tutelage of Sauron disguised as
the Elf Annatar, the Lord of Gifts.
Then, by himself, he creates the more powerful
Three Rings.
After Sauron reveals himself and forges the
One Ring, things go south pretty quickly for
Celebrimbor.
In the second episode of the first season,
Celebrimbor personally asks for Elrond's assistance
in building a tower that will house the most
powerful forge ever created by Elves, Humans,
or Dwarves.
It's a foreboding look at the master craftsman's
dark fate.
Though we likely won't see his fall from grace
until much later in the series.
Some fans have complained about Charles Edwards'
look as Celebrimbor.
But however cranky they currently feel, fans
might rest a little easier knowing he is a
renowned actor of both stage and screen.
He's starred in shows such as "The Crown"
and "Downton Abbey," as well as productions
of "Richard II" and "Much Ado About Nothing."
In short, Celebrimbor is in very good hands.
In 2019, "Deadline" reported that "Game of
Thrones" star Joseph Mawle had been cast as
the show's villain, Oren.
Since Sauron is the principal threat to Middle-earth
during the Second Age, this led many to assume
"Oren" was a production codename and that
Mawle was, in fact, playing the Dark Lord himself.
They were half right.
As it turns out, thanks to a leaked character
sheet, "Oren" is indeed a pseudonym for a
character named Adar.
The sheet describes the character as an "Elf,
tortured, corrupted, turned [into a] warlord."
Subsequent leaks and rumors suggest Adar will
lead an Orc-band hunting an enigmatic artifact,
and that he will face off against Sauron.
Most intriguingly, Adar may be revealed to
be one of Galadriel's brothers, perhaps the
same brother she's avenging as the series
begins.
This would be an astonishing break from Tolkien's
canon.
Imagining Galadriel's brother as a corrupted
warlord borders on the sacrilegious.
At the very least, it will be fascinating
to see how McKay and Payne might attempt to
pull off a twist like this.
Prince Durin IV is set to be one of the most
important Dwarven characters in "The Rings
of Power."
But who is he?
Durin IV is a Second Age ruler of Khazad-dûm
and a bearer of one of the rings of power.
His name is important.
Every once in a while, a prince or king of
the House of Durin is born who is almost identical
in appearance and manner to Durin the Deathless,
eldest of the Dwarves, who first awoke many
millennia ago.
These Dwarves are named Durin and are believed
by their kin to be a genuine reincarnation
of the original.
In total, six dwarves have been given the
name Durin throughout Middle-earth's history.
While it's currently unclear what specific
part Prince Durin will have to play in the
series, it will have something to do with
Celebrimbor's forge.
And you can safely bet he'll be playing it
from within the kingdom of Khazad-dûm, later
known as Moria.
Tolkien writes in "The Lord of the Rings"
that even as Sauron's forces spread across
Middle-earth, Khazad-dûm remained unconquered,
due to the strength and bravery of its people.
Prince Durin will likely lead them for much
of the show's run.
The Dwarven storyline in "The Rings of Power"
poses a curious question.
If Durin IV is the prince of Khazad-dûm,
who's the king?
The answer: Durin III.
Despite the fact that, in Tolkien's writings,
Durin III and Durin IV live thousands of years
apart, they'll be brought together as father
and son in the new series by its condensed timeline.
This will avoid huge time jumps and associated
issues with human characters' mortality.
"You've always had sandstone in your granite
as far as the elves were concerned."
In the original text, Durin III has a much
more explicit role in the events surrounding
Sauron's rise than Durin IV.
This is the king who is first gifted a ring
of power by Sauron and who later leads his
Dwarves into battle against the Dark Lord
before retreating to Khazad-dûm and closing
the Doors of Durin for good.
It should be expected that the relationship
between father and son will be severely tested
as the days grow darker for the Dwarves of
Khazad-dûm.
Rounding out the show's Dwarven protagonists
is Princess Disa.
Currently, there's not a lot known about Disa.
In the second episode of "The Rings of Power,"
she's introduced as Durin IV's strong-willed
and loving wife, and the mother to two very
energetic children.
A leak that occurred before the show premiered
suggests that Season 1 will include a Dwarven
"religious sect."
Given that Disa can be seen singing at a Dwarven
ceremony in one of the trailers, could Disa
be a leader of this group or some kind of
priestess?
How might she play into the politics of the
subterranean kingdom?
What impact will she have on the fates of
the two Durins?
Only time will tell.
Arondir was created for "The Rings of Power."
He's one of the Silvan Elves, who populate
the Greenwood and Lothlórien.
But Arondir's journey takes him far beyond
these forest realms.
Arondir falls into a forbidden romance with
Bronwyn, a human woman, while stationed at
a watchtower in the Southern Lands.
The storyline seems inspired by other Human-Elf
romances in Tolkien's work.
Aragorn and Arwen in "The Lord of the Rings"
and Beren and Lúthien in "The Silmarillion"
are prominent examples.
Though it has yet to be revealed what troubles
might underlie Arondir and Bronwyn's relationship.
"Twice in known history has a pairing between
elves and humans even been attempted and on
each occasion, it ended in tragedy."
Somewhat less murky is the setting for this
drama.
Bronwyn's village, Tirharad, was created for
the series, but the name, literally "near
Harad," suggests it's close to Harad, a mysterious
region located south of Mordor.
The view from Arondir's watchtower reveals
a lot about this land.
The geography of the valley below bears a
striking resemblance to the river Anduin,
the hills of Emyn Arnen, and the Ephel Dúath
mountain range that makes up Mordor's western border.
This could mean much of Arondir's Season 1
story takes place in and around the forests
later known as Ithilien the perfect home for
a lovesick wood-Elf.
An inhabitant of Tirharad, Bronwyn is a healer
and a single mother to son Theo.
By episode two, there is still little else
known about the woman who loves Arondir.
However, she quickly proves her resourcefulness
and determination when she saves Theo from
a goblin that has burrowed up from beneath
her house.
This occurs shortly after she returns from
her hometown which has been destroyed under
mysterious circumstances.
Using the severed head of the goblin, she
convinces her fellow villagers to abandon
their homes in the event that Tirharad suffers
the same fate.
Early in the series, Theo discovers a broken
sword hidden in the floorboards of a barn.
The weapon is currently a total mystery.
For a while, speculation ran rampant that
it could be Gurthang, the sword of Túrin Turambar.
However, rights restrictions prevent Amazon
from using material found solely in "The Silmarillion."
Now that we can watch the full episodes and
have gotten a good look at the design of the
sword's hilt and pommel, and Sauron's mark
on the blade, this proves that it's definitively
a weapon of the Dark Lord.
It's clear that Theo has some kind of connection
to the wider events of the Second Age, and
that the Tirharad storyline will reach far
beyond the secret romance at its core.
Another character created for "The Rings of
Power," Halbrand is a mortal man running from
his past.
By episode 2, we still know little about the
mysterious figure, though he clearly has some compassion.
As Halbrand and Galadriel attempt to survive
on a makeshift raft, the Elf is dragged under
the waves during a powerful storm.
Halbrand dives in and rescues her from a watery
grave.
This of course is after he abandoned several
other survivors from his ship when it was
attacked by a giant sea monster.
In one of the character posters for the show,
Halbrand is seen holding a sword with a horsehead pommel.
While it might be easy to assume this has
something to do with the Rohirrim, it's worth
remembering that the Horse-lords of Rohan
don't exist at this point in Middle-earth's history.
Halbrand's sword likely indicates he is Númenórean.
Tolkien writes in "Unfinished Tales" that
the Dúnedain loved horses and riding and
became so attuned to their steeds, that they
could call them to their side by merely thinking it so.
There have also been images of him wearing
a tunic marked with a solar symbol similar
to one found on another character poster.
Fans have speculated this icon may belong
to the Númenórean noble Elendil.
That's as far as our knowledge of Halbrand
goes, currently.
It'll probably be a while before we find out
who he really is, what he's running from,
and what he might become.
The Stranger is by far the most mysterious
character in "The Rings of Power."
He arrives in Middle-earth via fireball, which
can be seen streaking across the sky.
The relationship between the Stranger and
the Harfoot Nori who first encounters him
seems to be a central storyline for the series.
The Stranger could be a wizard, but he probably
isn't.
Even if he is, he almost certainly won't be
the one you're thinking of.
Gandalf, Radagast, and Saruman all come to
Middle-earth in the Third Age, long after
the events of the show take place.
The Stranger might be one of the two Blue
Wizards, but it seems odd to introduce one
with such fanfare and not the other.
All things considered, it's not particularly
plausible that the Stranger is one of the Istari.
So who is he?
Well, you might want to consider a character
you won't find elsewhere on this list, someone
who is guaranteed to play a major role in
the series.
One of the most famous aspects of Sauron's
story during the Second Age is that he comes
to the Elves disguised in a form so fair,
that few suspect his true identity.
What better way of delivering a truly shocking
twist than to make the audience believe they're
watching a kindly wizard befriend a humble
Harfoot, when they are, in fact, witnessing
the return of the new Dark Lord?
Nobody expected to see Hobbits in "The Rings
of Power," mostly because they don't show
up in Middle-Earth's history until the Third
Age.
And yet, here they are, or at least, their
ancestors.
The Harfoots, like the Hobbits, are short
and have hairy feet, but that's where the
resemblance ends.
The Harfoots are a nomadic group, still searching
to find their place in the world.
The show's featured Harfoots, Nori Brandyfoot,
Poppy Proudfellow, Largo Brandyfoot, and Marigold
Brandyfoot encounter the Stranger on their
travels, which changes their lives forever.
The series' depiction of this tribe of halflings
is almost entirely lifted from "Concerning
Hobbits," the first chapter of "The Lord of
the Rings."
This prologue explains that, in the so-called
"Wandering Days," Hobbits inhabited the upper
vales of Anduin to the east of the Misty Mountains.
According to Tolkien,
"The Harfoots had much to do with Dwarves
in ancient times, and long lived in the foothills
of the mountains."
Only when the fortress of Dol Guldur rose
in the early Third Age did the Hobbits migrate
westwards, eventually settling in the lands
that became the Shire.
Clearly, these aren't the simple, merry gardeners
we all know and love.
But the Harfoots' tale should nevertheless
offer up a tantalizing opportunity to explore
the secret history of one of Middle-earth's
most remarkable races.
"I can't help but feel that there's wonders
in this world beyond our wandering."
Because of the show's condensed timeline,
we can assume the movers and shakers of late
Númenórean history will be present from
early on, including Isildur, son of Elendil
and future king of Gondor.
At this point in time, Isildur is heir to
the lordship of Andúnië, a seaport located
on the island's west coast.
Notably, he is not yet king, and at the beginning
of the story, does not expect to become one.
As the days grow darker and Sauron's shadow
falls upon Númenor, however, Isildur will
doubtlessly be drawn into the Dark Lord's
deadly schemes.
If you're familiar with "The Lord of the Rings,"
you know this ends tragically.
One report claims he'll accompany Galadriel,
Elendil, and the Númenórean queen Míriel
on a maritime journey to Middle-earth.
Where exactly are they going and why?
Your guess is as good as ours.
Better known to "Lord of the Rings" fans as
High King of the Dúnedain and founder of
both Gondor and Arnor, Elendil's rise to glory,
and eventual death at the hands of Sauron
is sure to be a key storyline in "The Rings
of Power."
Early on, though, he's merely a Númenórean
lord, albeit a powerful one.
It's rumored that Elendil will head up recruitment
efforts and lead the Númenórean fleet on
its voyage to Middle-earth.
Tolkien writes in the appendices to "The Lord
of the Rings" that the Númenóreans began
to settle in Middle-earth around the year
S.A. 1200, a few hundred years before the
forging of the Rings of Power.
Since the series condenses the timeline to
a single generation, it makes sense that Season
1 will see the island nation spread its influence
across Middle-earth.
Elendil, it appears, will lead that effort.
As the seasons go by, expect to see him come
increasingly into conflict with Pharazôn,
king of Númenor, as the latter falls under
the influence of the Dark Lord.
"The past is dead.
We either move forward, or we die with it."
An epic saga is only as great as its monsters.
While Sauron will undoubtedly be doing much
of the heavy lifting in this department in
"The Rings of Power," Númenórean king Pharazôn
is nothing to be trifled with.
Pharazôn the Golden becomes king of Númenor
after forcibly marrying Míriel, daughter
of Tar-Palantir, the previous king.
After Sauron conquers much of Middle-earth
and declares himself King of Men, an infuriated
Pharazôn invades the mainland, swiftly and
decisively defeating the Dark Lord.
When the Númenóreans take Sauron back to
their homeland as a hostage, however, he quickly
gets to work corrupting them for his own ends.
Pharazôn's subsequent fall into darkness
has world-changing consequences.
It appears that at the beginning of Season
1, Pharazôn is merely a subject of Tar-Palantir
and an advisor to his future wife Míriel.
The show's Pharazon is a brilliant, authoritative,
and self-important type, which suggests the
character's wicked personality is already
fully formed, even if his tragic fate has
yet to play out.
Míriel is the daughter of Tar-Palantir, the
king of Númenor, and the unwilling wife-to-be
of Pharazôn.
Tolkien wrote little about Tar-Míriel, aside
from the disturbing nature of her marriage,
but it appears that she'll be a significant
part of the Númenórean storyline in "The
Rings of Power."
It appears that Míriel will experience visions
of Númenor's eventual destruction.
It's also reported that Míriel will be a
queen during the events of the show, though
her father is still alive.
It's not yet known why this might be.
It's said that she'll be a savvy, intelligent,
and compassionate ruler, and will see action
in at least one battle after joining the Númenórean
expedition to Middle-earth.
It's clear that the show's version of Míriel
will have much more impact on the history
of Middle-earth than her literary counterpart.
Tar-Palantir is unusual among the late kings
of Númenor.
Though his immediate predecessors mistrusted
the Elves and the god-like Valar, he takes
a royal name in the Elvish language Quenya,
as well as the Quenyan title "Tar," as opposed
to "Ar," taken from the Númenórean language.
This puts him at odds with his own people,
who are provoked by Pharazôn into open rebellion.
After Tar-Palantir dies, Pharazôn usurps
the throne and marries his daughter, Míriel.
Tar-Palantir is definitely in the show, though
he likely won't be a major player.
We currently have no idea who'll be playing
him.
Most probably, Tar-Palantir will be an elderly
ruler with diminished authority as the series opens.
His main purpose will be to open up a power
vacuum, allowing the villainous Pharazôn
to ascend to the throne of Númenor.
"The Rings of Power" will feature several
ancillary Númenórean characters, all of
whom are original to the series.
The first is Eärien, Isildur's sister, who
is played by Ema Horvath.
Eärien is set against Isildur's decision
to join the Númenórean expedition to Middle-earth.
At one point, she chases him through the city
streets as he leads his soldiers to war.
Finally, there's Kemen.
As Pharazôn's son, Kemen will spend Season
1 involved in a romance with Eärien.
Kemen is played by Leon Wadham, but it's unclear
what his role in the larger story of "The
Rings of Power" will be.
As Galadriel narrates the early days of Arda,
she speaks briefly about the Years of Trees,
and the great wars that dominated the First
Age.
Shortly after, we meet her brother, Finrod
Felagund.
As her narration continues, it's revealed
that he is one of the great Elven warriors
determined to end Morgoth's reign of terror
in Middle-earth.
Much of the introduction to "The Rings of
Power" is condensed, likely because a majority
of the story takes place during the Second
Age, but the particular battle that Galadriel
references might be the culmination of, and
ultimate end to, the First Age.
There's a lot to digest here.
In Tolkien's writing, Finrod is an Elven king
and brother of Galadriel.
He plays a key role in the events of the First
Age and eventually gives his life to save
Beren from torture at the hands of Sauron,
who at that point is merely a lieutenant of
the Dark Lord Morgoth.
The battle in question could be the epic Dagor
Bragollach or even a glimpse of Beren's quest
for the Silmaril.
Unfortunately, most of this material is found
in "The Silmarillion," which means Amazon
Studios can't use it for the series.
Luckily, the appendices of "The Lord of the
Rings" do mention a few key details about
Finrod, including his familial relationship
with Galadriel and the manner of his death.
The odds are that Finrod's appearance in "The
Rings of Power" will be relegated to the show's
prologue, which, with some clever trickery
and editing, could feasibly depict Middle-earth's
ancient history without committing copyright
infringement.
In May 2022, Amazon invited a number of Tolkien
fan blogs, websites, and YouTubers to a special
event in London, where they were introduced
to the showrunners and shown footage from
"The Rings of Power."
Information about the event has since started
popping up all over the internet.
According to several sources, show creators
Patrick McKay and John D. Payne told the attendees
they have plans for all the characters in
the Second Age, specifically naming Celeborn
and Celebrían as examples.
These names will be familiar to fans of "The
Lord of the Rings."
Celeborn is Galadriel's husband, while Celebrían
is Elrond's ill-fated wife.
Neither Celeborn nor Celebrían will be appearing
in Season 1.
For a long time, their absence from the cast
list was pretty conspicuous.
Now, though, we know that these two characters
will simply be making their debut at a later point.
This makes total sense.
Considering how many characters are due to
appear in the series, it stands to reason
that a few may need to be kept off the board
for a while.
And, if nothing else, it's greatly reassuring
to know that the storytellers behind "The
Rings of Power" know exactly where their tale
is headed.